hello folks and welcome to
rational science um
we have a great show today a busy show
and so we're gonna get right to it for
those of you who are new
um we divide our lecture in three parts
first part we deal with extinction quite
a popular subject really
my favorite is neanderthals i do quite a
bit of
research on the neanderthal love the
subject and so
i dedicate some time to that aside from
physics
then we're going to do a little bit of
physics uh today's
tunneling day we're gonna figure out
what
tunneling means or is for the purposes
of quantum mechanics
maybe uh like wormholes in
general relativity i don't know we'll
find out
and then at the end we're gonna open the
floor for comments
comments that have been made since
uh the last time that i had my lecture
so you know if you have questions
put them down uh we try to address all
the questions
and what we do we address them at the
next uh
lecture and the reason uh the main
reason for that is that
you want to have a good answer and
sometimes you know those
answers right off the cuff are not the
best of answers
so it's good to figure out what the
person's asking and
so that you can answer the question
property
okay so let's get started we're going to
do a little bit of extinction
and or subjects related to extinction i
remember here we're saying that
the global economy is going to collapse
and by the way i have a tremendous
toothache
i wasn't going to give the lecture today
but i put a
an aspirin against my gum and apparently
that
calmed it down so i hope i can do it all
right
if i don't smile too much you know why
see when you get to my age i'm going on
69 this year
well um you can't fight gravity forever
sometimes
gravity wins and your teeth start
falling down to the ground okay so here
we go
our first uh issue has to do with a
comment i made the other day really
which was related to
google apple and facebook
uh some of these companies are being
regulated regulated you know they want
to break them up maybe because they're
too big
like they did with the baby bells that's
one option another option is to tax them
at a higher rate especially in this
these days of cobit where they've taken
such uh
draconian uh measures the politicians
uh to keep people inside the houses a
lot of people are out of work
and so they get to get their taxes from
somewhere and they're
i guess they're going to tax the big
corporations
and there was a a lawsuit or
or an action by the european government
french government specifically in this
case against one of these big
corporations
and here you see it france finds google
500 million euros in new copyright row
actually it was closer to 600 million
euros which is like 700 million
dollars okay so a big fine against
google
i'm not sure if they're going to appeal
it i'm not sure they can
and it says long running battle has
centered on claims that google has
been showing articles pictures and
videos produced by media outlets
when displaying search results without
adequate compensation
despite the seismic shift of global
advertising revenues towards the
search giant okay so that's uh
the main gripe against google and faced
with dwindling print subscriptions
media outlets argue that google should
be giving them
a bigger cut of advertising revenues
from search results that display their
content
okay and google's argument was that
[Music]
some of these companies they get their
revenue by
traffic being diverted to them and these
companies uh
say that's not enough you should also
give us a piece of the advertising
revenue that's what this case was about
and friends
competition watchdog competition
watchdog what the hell is that
on tuesday slept googled with 500
million euros 593 million
oh dollars okay maybe i was wrong 600
million dollars
fine for failing to negotiate in good
faith
with media companies over the use of
their content under eu
copyrights rules the biggest
ever find imposed by what the
competition
authority see it used to be the
anti-trust
now they call it the competition
authority
anyways they're going after some of
these big comp companies and the
question is
whether uh
first whether it's a good idea that's
one question you know because
you would think that assuming that
google becomes richer
it becomes bigger it hires more people
you know and you would think it puts
people to work that's one way of looking
at it
another way of looking at it is that
maybe they're already too big maybe you
got to break them up
okay like the baby bells another one is
that maybe you should tax them at a
higher rate because they're making
uh you know
terrible uh profits
okay maybe we should spread the uh the
good
uh the bonanza around you know among the
people
somehow through government so there's
all different
philosophies and political uh
ways of addressing the issue and the
question is which one will they follow
okay but apparently they uh not only
them but
i was reading that australia and some
other company
countries are also trying to target
these big corporations
and they're either going after their
taxes or
regulating them or maybe even suggesting
that they should be broken up
again we don't know what's going to
happen there okay
uh more closer to extinction uh
we had uh some questions on the
neanderthals okay
again a subject i absolutely love okay
and this fella says out of africa
hypothesis is really fragile
and idiot in my opinion and new evidence
neanderthal skeleton was recently found
in the middle east
and it is older than european ones
okay uh middle east i guess it could be
israel
maybe syria maybe iraq they found some
caves there and they found
allegedly allegedly neanderthal
uh skulls or bones or fossils okay
and based on those fines they they
you know uh reached conclusions okay
this file read something i don't know
where uh he didn't give any
reference uh but he says that uh
neanderthals that were found somewhere
in middle east are older than european
ones
i don't know i have great doubts okay
here's the
oldest one we have the oldest skull we
have of a neanderthal and that's the
uh we can get it up here ah go on the
other side
give me a second here
and uh this is the oldest skull is from
italy
saco pastore uh number one and that's uh
130 to 100 000 years ago
and again wide ranges because the
farther back in time
the harder it is to date usually uh they
date it with things that are around
there
you can't carbon date these because
carbon dating doesn't go beyond 50 000
years
so you look at other clues and you
reach an approximate date that's why the
data's
the range is so wide okay that's saco
pastor that's
supposedly the oldest neanderthal skull
we have today
okay and that's in italy and i don't
think you'll find
one in uh in the middle east
uh and here's a an even older one and
this is
not a neanderthal it's his forefather
this is heidelbergensis the swanskom
skull
approximately 400 000 years ago again
very wide ranges here okay
maybe 400 000 years ago and that's came
out of
england and it's not really a it's not
really a man it's a woman first of all
a female and it's not on hand i thought
it's uh
their parents heidelbergensis homo
heidelbergensis and
so what this shows okay together with
some other
uh evidence that's out there is that
there were two-legged creatures like
monkeys like gorillas like humans
something like that uh in england
okay and uh so if they were there
already at that time and the theory is
that neanderthals descended from them
and the end of those were born in europe
you know by the time maybe homo erectus
maybe heidberg
one of those uh was out then came
neanderthal which descended from that
group that originally was
in western europe so um
you know if you follow that line and you
cannot think that
uh what this individual is suggesting
which is that
maybe perhaps um
the neanderthals came from the middle
east
okay so i don't know about what this
fellow is saying here i
don't accept that hypothesis i don't i
don't use that as an assumption
i say that the ones that we the
skeletons the fossils the
bones that we find in the middle east
are not
at all neanderthal there's some other
species
okay and uh i'm just gonna one more time
show you this
okay and this is these uh this is a
paper
uh written um by experts
who look at these bones and they give
you their five cents worth
again their opinion but you know they
say that the
bones that they find in israel
especially
and and also the ones in iraq they found
uh a cave there as well full of bones
and they say that there is little
actually little evidence for the
existence of a
southwest asiatic neanderthal population
in israel during the middle paleolithic
period
human fossils originally labeled as
neanderthals were subsequently
reevaluated
and defined otherwise a horizontal
mandibular foramen they go out there and
they say uh
has uh which character is who rises 61
percent of the neanderthals
is absent and they mentioned three of
the sites there
shannon darbien uh one in iraq
okay so you know the uh neanderthals
the alleged neanderthals that you find
in uh
the middle east and the levant uh
they don't they don't match exactly
their significant differences in other
words
with the so-called with a bandwidth of
the
original the classical neanderthals of
western europe
of spain france belgium and germany
and possibly uh england if they ever
find one
there okay they haven't found really a
bone there but don't put it past them
someday they might
okay anyways uh these folks seem to
uh say that what you see in the levant
are not uh neanderthals and the reason i
like that
uh proposal that assumption that theory
if you want
um is that i cannot imagine neanderthal
who i make the assumption that they were
born in europe
from uh first from um
going farther back right from homo
erectus and then from
heidelbergensis man of heidelberg
i think that's the line that gave origin
to neanderthals
once the neanderthals were born they
were born in the cold
they were born in the arctic they were
used to that weather
they were polar bears they were like the
uh
woolly mammoths of uh human uh
human woolies the willy man and so
you know not only they did not need
clothes but this was their
natural habitat and so they they had no
problem they walked in the snow they
they couldn't even sleep in the snow
they were built
for the snow and and such an animal such
a creature
you know i don't think would go to the
middle east
farther south where the warm weather was
uh raging closer to the equator it's
like you're asking a polar bear to go to
the equator does that happen
i don't think so and i don't think
neanderthal had any reason
to go farther south because he had a lot
of game
and as far as i'm concerned you know
humans
came out of africa they went through the
middle east and they went
north and the reason is why
well i think they were either following
the herds or they were looking for
food and they found more food up north
and in the south
and they ventured into europe and when
the neanderthals were gone
you know they uh settled in europe
and they lasted you know to today and
the reason for that is there was enough
gain
in the north there was not enough game
in the south apparently that's why the
migration was northward
there was no reason for climatic reasons
and for food reasons for the
neanderthals to go
south to the levant and so you know um
this is uh my little map on that
okay i'm saying that you know there's no
chance that the neanderthals which were
probably like gorillas somewhat like
them in other words they were
woolly the woolly man i don't think they
would go south
uh to you know mount camels
in in the middle east no i think they
stayed up north where they hunted
uh willie mammoths and uh
the uh european buffalo and so on there
was no need for them to go
south at all and so you know those
uh that those uh um
investigative researchers that claim
that they found
neanderthal bones in the middle east
well uh they should think again i don't
think uh
hume uh neanderthals ever went south
i think they stayed in europe and uh
above a certain uh parallel
um certainly uh around italy and upwards
okay that that's i think their range
another fellow uh says regarding clothes
uh remember i'm saying that neanderthals
did not wear clothes
at all any footwear or anything and this
bill said instead of searching for a
no because i'm saying that the needle is
one of the
arguments against clothes we haven't
found any needles
in neanderthal sites and we have over 80
sites in europe where they found
neanderthal
either bones or tools or some
some evidence of presence
of the neanderthals there and they never
found a needle
in any of these sites and you would
think that one needle you know
made a bone you know
we would have found something like that
they found other things that are made of
bone and wood that survived
and we never found a needle out of 80
sites
you know i mean you would think that if
they all
wore clothes they all had needles
the women maybe i don't know it was a
division of labor and she did
you know the women did the sewing uh you
know i don't think uh
there's no reason for us not to find at
least one needle
okay in all these sites and so you know
they found bones tools and weapons
but uh in about 80 neanderthal sites but
no needle
and needles appear in the record
approximately 36 000 years ago in other
words
we're talking about cro-magnon
cro-magnon and here
i give you a little evidence okay this
is
uh the first needle we have on record
the kostenki
needle in russia and it's dated anywhere
between 20 and 36 000 years ago
okay and yeah that first one there uh
does look at like a needle okay letter a
there
so i would think that is a needle and
that's maybe when they appeared
and i think it may have appeared again
30
say 30 maybe i'll take it even up to
40 000 years ago as soon as man
humans cro-magnons entered europe
uh it was cold and they probably started
building clothes
that's when clothes i believe were
invented for the first time
and that's what appears to me there's
another argument that it has to do with
lice
and you can look that up that's another
argument out there and that dates
close to 175 000 years ago at least
and i disagree with that because um
i don't think man in africa needed
clothes
okay but they say uh they
uh the argument is that lice uh
went from body lice to hair lice and
that's because they started wearing
clothes
okay so that's the argument in a
nutshell okay
anyways uh they found a wooden spear
four hundred thousand years ago that's
the
[Music]
this little thing here the shenanigans
spear
in germany and so it's made out of wood
and yeah
wood does tend to survive sometimes you
know under certain conditions
if this survived went in the needle
survived uh 40 000 years ago
okay so we're talking about 10 times as
far
back and it's there and we don't find a
needle
40 000 years ago so again uh
my my argument with all this is that you
know you you have to look at
the entire evidence to find out what
evidence
might fit um
the facts okay of course we are
selective with
evidence many times because we can't get
our theories through and one
every piece of evidence maybe negates
our theory and so we
kind of strip it under the rug so to
speak you've got to be honest with
yourself and look at all the evidence
and i try to look at pros and cons of
all the arguments as much as possible as
much as i can find
i reach my own conclusions and all i can
do is just share my 10 cents worth with
you
my my idea is that neanderthals were
born in europe they had no reason to go
south they wore no clothes
and humans never entered europe until
the neanderthals were gone because
otherwise the neanderthals
who were in their own turf which did not
need clothes
uh they knew their environment and they
probably marked their territories i
don't know by
spraying urine all over the trees
you know to ward any enemies uh even on
another neanderthal because
neanderthals were the worst enemies of
neanderthals okay the only guys who
could bring them down was another
neanderthal just like a lion is the
worst
enemy of a lion so i think the
neanderthals were born in europe they
never left europe they had no reason to
uh there was enough game there to keep
them busy
and hung and uh fed and only when their
population pyramid overturned that's
when they were gone
and humans were finally able to enter
into europe
and find all these bones these skeletons
whatever they found there and they said
okay
uh someone was here but he's gone they
probably thought it was another human
okay that's the way i i see that in
general terms
okay continue with cold near those cold
people are wondering about that right
uh fella says you could use the
toothpick to poke a
bunch of holes in hinds and then just
weave the string
to the hose without even using a tool
yeah correctly but the
issue is that that needle you know is
what we haven't found
okay so there's no evidence at least of
it i wish there were
to show that neanderthals were closed i
don't think we're gonna have ever find
evidence of needles okay because i don't
think they ever invented the needle
i don't think they ever did sewing and
you need to sew
hides together in order to prepare
clothes you can't just
you know throw something on top of you
yourself and i don't think they would
have done that anyways they weren't into
that i i think they didn't need clothes
okay so there was no need for them to
invent something they didn't need
uh any more than a polar bear needs
something to cover itself okay
then you would hide cl uh you would have
hide clothing
you would have hide clothing instead of
freezing to death
yeah again see these people think that
anandato would freeze to death he was
there
four hundred 000 years or so maybe less
maybe more
and he never froze to death why would he
freeze to death
okay if he was made for the cold does a
polar bear
freeze to death does he know what cold
means
okay even a dog is smart enough to get
under a blanket
yeah you're maybe your puppy you know at
home the domesticated dog the one that's
already
been living thousands of years uh with
man
uh inside a house he's not used to the
cold you can't
take your your dog to the to the uh
i don't know to the polar regions to
northern canada or northern russia and
just let them go there in the
freezing snow he's gonna he's gonna die
of
frost he's gonna die of cold but
uh that i know of no uh
polar bear dies of cold no wolf none of
those die
okay of cold another major motivation
for inventing clothing
is shoes if you don't wear some kind of
footwear outside you'll die
a lot faster yeah you will the question
whether a neanderthal would
or at very less you will at least you'll
be experiencing tons of pain like
walking on hot
shards of glass or legos nobody can
tolerate that [ __ ] for a long for long
even if they had neanderthal feet
especially not females
poor uh you know they're all females
they had to go in the high heel shoes so
their feet wouldn't touch the
snow i guess right okay let me why isn't
this guy up this
this poor fellow here he's so mistaken
uh
you know wolves don't uh usually wear
clothes but apparently some of them you
know wear
these night caps so they don't freeze
their ears
uh polar bears you know they put on
gloves even if it's baseball mitts you
know they don't care
as long as they have their hands warm
you know the uh mastodons they
they put on their uh their diapers there
so they have their butts uh warm
and will you rhinos you know they they
wear socks uh they they
you know they have to do that because
otherwise their feet will get cold
then you see the penguin and the
penguins feet
now the the feet are directly in contact
with the snow
i mean do they wear shoes
so so the question is do these animals
need clothes
and this fella seems to think that they
do and maybe he should go out to the
north pole
somewhere you know or wherever these
animals are found maybe the south pole
and uh you know
[Music]
put something around them so they won't
freeze to death okay
so uh no uh i think this fellow
this fellow is so mistaken and so many
people believe like
he does that uh you know these animals
would freeze to death
and they don't understand that they
don't these animals are built for cold
and here's um here's a good old
neanderthal you know he's got to wear
his uh
ear muffs and sandals for otherwise he
he's going to get his feet called that's
what this law believes
so yeah i doubt that very much i don't
think neanderthals had anything to do
with the cold they didn't know what cold
was they never had it in their
dictionary
they never say oh it's cold today never
happened
they were born in the snow
they lived in caves you know they
probably
uh had fires as well but when they went
out they didn't dress up and say oh it's
cold outside i think i'm gonna dress up
no no they just went out like
no problem it wasn't on an issue with
them they could go out in the cold and
they if they used fire maybe they used
it for cooking
you know we don't really know exactly
what they did with the fire i would
think they
did some cooking okay but other than
that uh
neanderthals did not need and they did
it also for defense you know they
they realized that with fire they could
keep some uh
you know some uh animal like a bear out
of the cave
so they are understood that they use it
as a weapon
uh other than that you know they could
go out there and
be in the snow every day no problem
and you might say well is that true well
here we have a case in modern day
history
okay now this is the 19th century but
it's it's still you know 100 years ago
okay and it was founded by mr darwin and
robert fitzroy okay and they were the
yagans okay
uh they were also known as the fueginos
because they're from tierra del fuego
south of argentina and chile okay and
that's
in 1883 they were essentially nude
and this is 50 years after
darwin saw them he saw him in 1833
and he put it in his diary so did
fitzroy
and what they said is that the women
especially
you know they would dive in the water
after their husbands
harpooned some fish or some
animal from the seas and they would pull
this
thing out the women did the diving and
he also died
for seashells collected seashells and
they were nude
in in the south and where and and the
british were completely astonished by
the resistance that these
yagans had to the cold and there you see
1922 they were civilized by them so
someone and they started wearing clothes
but
before then they were nude and so
look up where tierra del fuego is uh
south of argentina and chile
and you tell me if you could live there
uh nude
okay if you want to do some some uh you
know start your nudist beach over there
you'd starve to that nobody would would
take off their clothes down here and the
youngins had no problem
they lived like that down there okay so
uh yeah if humans can do it and i'm sure
the yavins were not
as well protected as the neanderthals
forget it the neanderthals had no
problem whatsoever with a cold they had
no idea what cold was
they never had the word in their
dictionary
okay uh talking about coal we have
someone talking about the cold war
i know a little bit about that and it
says
looks like the usa lost the cold war
long term
okay remember the cold war was
originally only between the ussr the
soviet union
as it became known later the ufsr
which means the you you know fewer and
fewer
socialist republic uh
uffs are and uh today well yeah they
stretch their hands across the uh divide
there with china
uh because they have both have a common
enemy and the united states is uh
blocking a lot of their stuff so they
decided to form a little bit of a
partnership there
against the united states but the way i
look at it today you know i look at it
very differently when i was
my 20s there i used to think of the
united states as an enemy that's how i
was raised that's what i saw around me
but over time you know you you start
seeing things a little more clearly
and the way i look at all these is as
mafias they're all mafias
okay it doesn't matter if it's the
united states any country in europe
russia china they're all mafias they all
have
politicians who rule and they try to do
whatever they can
uh to get their countries rolling or
maybe just to
get in you know become rich themselves
and their friends and the way i look at
it uh you know i don't pay attention to
politics anymore
and the reason for that is you know if
you can't do anything about it
why even get excited about it so israel
is torturing the palestinians you have
war between pakistan
uh pakistanis and indians you have uh
fighting
uh you know just about everywhere really
you know
china against taiwan and so on there's
hot spots
all over the world any one of them can
break you know the uh
the peace out there am i concerned
anymore about
all that not at all because again i
can't do anything about it
so why get excited and say well this is
justice and that's injustice and
if i can't do anything about it so the
best way i always recommend to
any of you out there the best way to
deal with the world
problems to solve them is turn your tv
off
you turn it off you solve the problem
for yourself
okay that's the way you should look at
it okay
so yeah i don't uh worry about the cold
war anymore
my only concern there is i hope all
these countries united states uh
china and russia i hope they keep going
upwards and uh
so that we live at least another 50
years
if we could do that you know so i don't
care if if they
torture if they kill if they murder i
really don't care as long as i mean
no problem um my only hope if if that's
what they need to do
to get the economy rolling forward do it
i don't care i'm not gonna even look i'm
not going to question it
okay i don't care because my only
interest is that
the world continues as much as it can
because again we're i'm saying the last
generation of humans on earth so i don't
care
how they do it i don't care if it's
illicit i don't care if it's immoral
if it's unethical uh what what the
government start doing
i don't care i really don't it's not my
problem anymore
it used to be my problem i used to lose
sleep over it no more i just
turned the tv off okay
another fella along the same line more
or less says a system of fiat will
always collapse
power can corrupt absolute power
corrupts absolutely famous saying
okay uh well um
the only thing i got to say about that
is that corruption is not what's going
to cause
the extinction of man i just want to
clarify that okay
what's going to cause the extinction of
man is this the overturning of the
uh it's not that's not what's going to
cause the extinction man the overturning
of the population pyramid
we are overturning that's going to
trigger
the collapse of the economy and that's
what's going to
cause the extinction of man in other
words that the overturning
of the ecological pyramid
we're going to have the many 8 billion
humans chasing a few
food there's going to be no food out
there why because
we're not going to produce it because
the global economy money is going to be
no more
and because money is no more no one has
any incentive to produce it
massively for the masses okay
corporations that produce just to
distribute to make money
no money no incentive no reason to
produce food
and no distribution and so what happens
is the ecological pyramid
overturns why does that depend on the
um population pyramid overturning
well because the fewer impart that's
just
one of the uh ingredients right in the
recipe
and it goes like this you know the fewer
people we have
the less demand we have and the less
demand we have
the the fewer things that big
corporations can sell both
goods and services and if they sell
less well there's attrition there's an
implosion of the economy okay so they
lay off workers
because uh they're not producing enough
because they're not selling enough
and that's a cycle that just keeps
rolling and rolling until
you have a collapse and i say that
that process is going to be exponential
just like it was exponential in the 19th
century going up
you know when we industrialize
essentially this is gonna be the same
thing but going down
and it's probably gonna be steeper
that's my guess on that
okay okay
let's move on here uh so i don't think
it's going to be corruption by the way
it's
corruption is it's just yeah it's in
uh it's in man man uh
will try to do the utmost
to become rich in general terms and in
order to do so they don't care how
they're going to do it
so corruption is part of the deal it's
part of history it's been there all
along like israel says but it's not
corruption that's going to cause the
extinction of man it's going to be
the overturning first of the population
pyramid
followed by the overturning of the
ecological
pyramid food our food pyramid okay
okay another fellow says here uh peter
patriarchal groups that live in cities
have a high
birth rate which proves this
urbanization myth to be
false which is what i'm suggesting okay
so i'm saying that all animals don't
have potential structures
yet they have offspring so you gotta
have a universal and right now you're
only talking about man you're not
talking about all
animals so you gotta do a research on
all animals
and there you see something uh you know
uh
how their fruits uh are attacked by
something that's alive and that living
thing grows to a certain point and then
no more then it
you know as their uh
world collapses underneath their feet so
to speak
right they cannot re continue
reproducing or reproducing reproducing
just expanding no they fall together
with
what's underneath them what they're
relying upon for sustenance
and that means that you know that's uh
what we call density dependent there
density dependent birth rates okay uh
you can't continue expanding forever if
what you're relying upon
is declining and that's what he's got to
understand as well
all species follow mother nature's law
of density dependent birth traits
okay and here you see the here's uh for
humans right the
global history
and here it goes uh it starts here in
the second
it starts the year i think at the
beginning of the
christian area uh year to zero then a
thousand
years shows you what's happening with
the world it just continues
uh becoming populated but see there are
regions that are not populated there
okay
and then in 2050 there won't be no
humans
okay i'm saying that we're dead by the
by the year 2050
and maybe some human here and there but
it's not going to restart the race again
okay the the species and
uh so i moved the other day i
showed the other day uh this which is uh
what the world looks like today and what
you see there
is all the regions the the major regions
that have very little population
see what we're the way we're set up
today the way we're
distributed population wise is in big
cities
you have cities like tokyo which are you
know
close to 40 million people i mean what
is it
and i think that's the with the greater
tokyo but the point is
people go to the cities today they they
abandon the countryside and they go to
the cities
and so we're not creating new new towns
or new villages we're not creating new
cities
what we're doing is evacuating the
countryside leaving that
that land to the big corporations
agricultural corporations
and we are moving in what is known as
the transition
uh to the cities so the cities are
becoming bigger
and when you have these big ant holes
then density dependent birth rates take
place
for cultural economic and um
social reasons okay so there are several
reasons
for why we don't have children in the
cities and it's got nothing to do with
patriarchal
not well not specifically with
patriarchal it's got to do with density
dependent birth rates and again the
higher the density
the fewer children you're gonna find
eventually okay
tokyo is is a prime example you know
uh japanese don't have children anymore
neither do russians why because russians
have what
two three cities that's it that's all
they have mega cities
uh moscow st petersburg you know
uh stalingrad as it was called
uh that's it um you know
these uh you know the united the
russia does not have many
cities it has a few cities that are big
and everybody's moving to those cities
from
the regions around there and so if
anything we're evacuating
the countryside not building villages
and towns
in the countryside it's the other way
around we're evacuating those
okay so in fact a lot of the old people
live in in towns and as they die
you know nobody replaces them because
there are no uh
industries going to the little towns
the industries are getting close around
the periphery of the big cities if
anything but never do they go into a
little town and say oh we're gonna
install
our big company here no it doesn't
really happen today
because all these corporations really
what they're doing is moving
to the cities where where the action is
and where
certain services are available you can't
go to a little town where there are no
services or
or it's uh many things are missing that
a corporation might need
they're not going to go to to a little
town because if they did then you know
the
young people might flock there and you
know to grow with the city
with a town but that doesn't happen
anymore we're not going to the towns
we're going to the cities it's the other
way around
okay anyways i encourage people to do
extinction 101 before they do extinction
102
meaning you want to do mass extinction
first
very few people tackle mass extinction
they want to do human
extinction everybody's an expert at
human extinction
i yet i have yet to find people who are
experts
in mass extinctions that occurred
already
which is what a theory is supposed to
explain you have to explain how the
animals in the past
died disappeared okay and so
that's the first one you got to tackle
then once you become an expert
at mass extinction well then you can
extrapolate those mechanisms see if
humans
you know can uh do something about those
as well
and the big question i put up out there
for anyone who wants to tackle it and
it's related to this again
and it's this if i can get it up there
all right i've lost it anyways uh it's
the question is
why did the animals in the seas die
approximately at the same time as the
animals on land
because that's happened in all
essentially mass extinctions
when the animal and land died more or
less the
ones who were flying died and more or
less the ones who were in the waters
died almost approximately at the same
time
and you have to ask why is that the case
why did these
animals die approximately at the same
time
because that might give you a clue
as to how mother nature does extinction
okay so keep that in mind
okay so let's get on with uh tunneling
today
well we've been dealing with several
properties
uh that quantum mechanics claims
they've observed whatever observed means
it does observe mean with two eyes like
observe like i
observed the girl who was taking off her
clothes
no nothing like that okay now uh
when they say observe they mean they
infer
but they say observe so that people
listen observe they say oh they saw it
with their two eyes
and so if they saw it with their two
eyes who's going to deny it here you
have all the so-called scientists and
they say we observed
you're going to question that i mean
you're going to say you need to go to
the lab
and when all these people are telling
you the same thing that they observed
something in the lab but it turns out
that
the so-called observation is not an
observation it's not with the two eyes
what they observed was the visible
things what they touch was the
tangible things okay and tangible things
are typically not
anything adam or below it's usually adam
or above
and adam that's a question also okay
they touch many atoms you know i can
touch a chair which is gazillions of
atoms yeah
but i can't touch one atom or i wouldn't
know if i did
and so you got to keep that in mind
these people use the word
and that's why i hate the word observe
in science it should be there
first because we don't do observations
and second because we cannot
observe that which is intangible and
invisible
mother nature is mediators for
gravity uh magnetism workings of the
atom
light etc uh they're all invisible
and intangible so we're not going to
detect them through a lab
experiment and we haven't in the last 10
000 years
no one has been able to determine what
mother nature uses because it's
invisible and intangible and you're not
going to figure out by running an
experiment you can run all the
experiments you want you won't be able
to touch or see
that which is invisible and intangible
and so the only way to look at this is
step back and find out how mother nature
could be doing
this magic trick and i give the example
always
you know um you see this guy
uh going like this and a box goes up
okay and it turns out you know the box
is attached to the rope
rope is attached around the pulley and
the guy's pulling on a pulley
on the rope through the pulley but the
question is if you didn't see the rope
and the guy was doing this and the box
goes up
are you gonna say it's just black magic
or are you
going to assume that there is something
that you simply can't see
that the guy is pulling on
and that's the same situation here we
can't see light
does that mean there is no mediator for
light because you can't see or touch it
you know you put your laser and you put
your hand right through it
and you're not hitting atoms or anything
you know you're not
hitting the things that uh or the
you know colliding against the the thing
that makes up light
your hand goes right through that does
that mean there's nothing there's
there's no physical
object there okay
and so the question is if it's
intangible
and invisible of course you're going to
run your hand right through the laser
beam
whatever entity is there and you're
going to say there's nothing there
because i can't see your touch
and so you got a problem because mother
nature have
has made specifically that mediator
invisible
and intangible and until you get that
through your thick skull
you're going to be running around in
circles and running experiments and
saying oh i'm going to run another
experiment see if i can detect it
you'll never be able to detect it
there's only one way in us sitting back
and visualizing how mother nature could
be doing all these things
with some object which is invisible and
intangible
so again what quantum mechanics does is
they found
all these properties all these phenomena
and what they do is describe the
phenomena they
observed or did not observe
and they have no idea what is mediating
that phenomena that's where we're at
today okay that's what quantum
mechanics and essentially all of
mathematical physics is all about
and so here's the recap that i've been
of what i've been talking about lately
and that's uh these properties that
uh quantum supposedly discovered
okay these are things that they saw
observed in the lab
what did they observe well they say they
observe the coherence
well what do we mean by that did they
see
an object do what is known as
decoherence which is a
phenomena a process a a verb
have they found the noun that does the
coherence
have they found the mechanism how mother
nature does this magic trick
and the answer is absolutely not they
have not
so here's a d coherence i call it
incoherence
okay and uh you see
the slit experiment and they say that
this particle because they do everything
they simulate everything with particles
it says the particle goes through both
slits
and why is that the case well they say
if if the slits weren't there
there would be coherence between these
two as essentially they show them as
particles but
they're going to turn them into waves
there's
going to say that these two waves are uh
in phase but it's because
something gets in the way and they
interact with your environment that it
becomes incoherent in other words uh
it's coherent until it interacts with
the environment
that's what these people are saying okay
and so yeah uh with that we still don't
know
how mother nature does it all they're
saying is if there's something there and
it
interacts with that something it becomes
incoherent
until then it was coherent but as soon
as interact
in fact with your vision or your
touching
then it becomes incoherent you can't
predict
what's going to happen or there's
interference of some kind
so listen with so they're not telling
you how it works
how the magic works they're just saying
we observed
right uh something happened and we're
going to call that
the coherence and we're going to use it
for technology
we don't know what it is we don't know
how to explain we don't care about that
we're just going to use it
because we found this effect that's what
they're saying
entanglement no different they uh what
is entanglement well it says that
uh what you have well here let me get
this up here
the uh entanglement means that one
particle here can affect another one
over there without a mediator without
anything between them
now what sense does that mean how can a
particle affect here
affect that one over there without any
mediator
and they just say that it does okay so
it does i'll concede i'll grant
what is that how does it how does it do
it how can we make sense of that
and the answer is it is so that's what
they say
well that's only a description and we
don't have an explanation
and they say well we can use it for
technology again it's it's all this
stuff about technology which is confused
with science
science we have to explain how how it
does
how does mother nature does this trick
not just describe and say it happens
yeah we we notice that when they move
this over here
that one moves over there in some
certain way like in this case i'm
showing
we have counter clockwise here and
chicago is over there and then when you
turn one of them around the other one
turns around instantaneously that's what
they found
in fact that's not what they found what
they really do is they have
polarizers where they check the
orientation
at that location so it's kind of like a
static
[Music]
experiment it's not something where
you're seeing
really motion at the cross section where
you put the polarizer
okay so keep that in mind okay uh
i used an ellipsometer when i was in the
semiconductor industry and that's
essentially how they do these things
they do it
using a an ellipsometer
okay next one superposition that's
another one that i covered
okay what a superposition well it says
that
while the horse gallops it also stands
still
what sense can that possibly make how
can something be standing still and
moving at the same time
and they say yeah a particle can vibrate
and not
vibrate at the same time it's excited
and not excited
at the same time what sense can you make
of that does that
make any sense that to you i mean if it
does well maybe i'm wrong i don't know
but i'm saying uh that's nonsense it's
called poppycock
it's idiocy irrationality now
use any of those words you're fine
surely this cat the cat is both dead and
alive what can that possibly mean how
can a
cat be both dead and alive and what they
use for that
is two features uh they use
complementary and
uncertainty and here you see the cat is
alive and dead
both until you open the box and you peek
inside
then it suddenly collapses to one of the
two states
and again they use all these
observations as they call them these
phenomena
you know superposition they use
uh the coherence uh complementary
uncertainty
they use all those they mix them up put
them in bunch them into one they say
we observed each one of these phenomena
and here's a complementarity okay the
next one there
neil sports complementary what does that
mean well it's duality it's
something they love they love all these
dualities light is both
a particle and a wave that's what uh
good o'neill says so you see the
particles they're rolling uh the yellow
ones
and so the light is both both
particles and waves waves being a bunch
of vectors only
particles i don't know how you can get
them to move up and down because it's
got to be oscillating
so we can't reconcile particles with
waves but they say
light is both particles and
waves and so what sense can you make of
that
what does that mean and again they say
well we don't understand that we don't
care because we're going to use it
for technology and as long as they find
some use for the
effect they're happy because they say
the rest is philosophy we're never going
to figure this out
and we can't figure it out why i'll tell
you why they can't figure it out
because they're using particles you
cannot explain this with particles
and with one-way mechanisms which is you
know what you see there
both waves and particles are outgoing
they allegedly come
out of the atom the atom produces the
waves the atom produces the particles
whichever or both
and shoots them outwards okay
and uh you know under the rope model
it's a bi-directional
mechanism so it's a lot different than
this there is no such thing as a wave
first of all
because again those are a bunch of
vectors that's all we're seeing moving
vectors
what is vector magnitude and direction
okay so what is that
uh mathematics that's what it is okay
and here you have um uncertainty
okay so this the other day also here's a
mr
heisenberg and his uncertainty principle
and what is he saying well he says that
you know the ball bounces at the same
time that
it stands still and see they're all
related all this
uncertainty complementarity together
with
the coherence and superposition they
have all these concepts all together
from different angles and they put them
together to try to give you
an explanation what's the explanation an
irrationality
they they give you something which is
absolute nonsense which is
duality that it has two aspects
which are contradictory which are
irreconcilable
motion and standing still you know
location
and that's what you have there you know
the ball stands still it also moves and
so this is the uncertainty principle if
you think uh
that's going to make your life any
better well they say they can use it in
technology
well we don't care if they can use it in
technology if they cannot explain what's
causing it if they cannot make sense of
that
and right now we have a problem because
we're reaching the end of the line
where i mean they've had this for a
hundred years now
quantum's been around for a hundred
years and
they cannot explain any of this and here
they're at the same starting point as
they were in 1926 1927
when they started concocting all this uh
so-called theory of quantum mechanics
today we've made no progress whatsoever
they have no explanation for any of this
all they have is more equations for
different aspects of this
and that's all they have and right now
they're they've kind of painted
themselves into a corner because
they still cannot give you an
explanation for this
and they've abandoned that it's like uh
richard feynman says you know they've
given up on that
so they don't have an explanation he
said that in 65
and here what we're uh 40 years 50 years
down the road
they still have no explanation for this
and so what more are they going to do
do you think they're going to find a
solution to this
and the answer is no and the reason they
cannot find a solution is they're
dealing with particles
mother nature cannot be using particles
this was the time to wipe the board
completely clean and start
all over and brainstorm some new
mediators we can't continue using
particles or waves
that's the issue and fields you know
it's not a physical object
field is a mathematical concept that is
a value at each point in space
that's all a focal field is so there is
no such thing as a field there's no such
thing as a wave and particles
right now we're not even using particles
we're not using the classical corpuscle
what we're using is uh zero dimensional
uh equations that's
that's what a particle is an equation
that's how it is uh function
okay and spin which we dealt with the
other day here it is
okay and that means that the dancer
spins both ways
okay clockwise and counterclockwise
until
you again see or touch him as soon as
you see or touch him he collapses to one
or both
uh to one of the two states okay
meanwhile he goes clockwise and
counterclockwise
that's what they're saying spin is
and it turns out spin is not even spin
spin is a static concept and it has to
do more with
orientation but as we explained the
other day
you know if they um if they use the
true spin first of all it doesn't match
what they observe
in the lab the effects they observed
and second uh they cannot explain
attraction with that anyways
so what if an electron spins how does
this electron from this atom over here
attract that electron from that atom
over there
how do you produce attraction with two
little balls
spin them any way you want them okay
spin the tops
one clockwise the other one
counterclockwise spin them both
clockwise spin them both
counterclockwise it doesn't matter
one top will not attract the other top
so at some point you got to put an
elongated mediator
between objects atoms right
in order to be able to explain how
mother nature does her things
then you can explain action at a
distance and the only
uh assumption you have to make is you
can't see or touch that mediator
why because that's not what an object is
an object is that which has
shape so yeah as long as you insist on
c touch and doing experiments
then you're in trouble you'll never
answer the question
okay um
here's a tunneling which is the next um
phenomenon we've seen all these other
ones this is another
crazy phenomenon of quantum mechanics
okay and it goes more or less like this
you have a snowball big
ball okay and it hits this mountain and
it bounces backwards okay that's what we
would expect for
a snowball to do okay it hits the
mountain bounces back
okay no problem there so far so good
okay what they uh say is why can't that
ball go up the mountain and climb over
it and go to the other side
okay and so here let's show that okay
it's gonna try to do that
gonna try to climb climb climb and it's
doesn't have the energy whatever that is
to reach the top and go
over the side of the mountain okay so
what happens is
they cannot explain uh if
they were to find uh the snowball on the
other side
that would be a miracle right there's no
way it can happen at least in classical
mechanics
you would need so much energy to get up
that mountain
that that's not what they observe in the
lab
okay so what is it that they observe in
the lab
well what they observe in the lab is
this okay they
observe that the ball is on the other
side
okay so now how do you explain that
turns out this uh
ball was rolling along it didn't climb
the mountain
it just went through it and they called
that tunneling it's like it went through
a tunnel
like the mountain had a tunnel in
between it
and so yeah now we have a problem
because we have to explain that
what do you mean it's got a tunnel what
is that uh
and the way they explain it is more or
less like this so hold on to your seats
right now because this is just
gonna drop you flat on flat face down on
the floor okay here it is
what they say is the the reason the ball
ends up
the snowball ends up on the other side
of the mountain is it rolls
and the snowball turns into a wave it
just
goes as a wave through the mountain and
then it arrives at the other side
night that neat man i wish i would have
thought of that that's the best
explanation you can have right
or is it i mean don't you call that
black magic
i mean not even the bible has this kind
of stuff
this is really ridiculous they're saying
that
the ball turns into a wave and that's
how it ends up on the other side
okay you say okay uh doesn't make any
sense
but okay what's the explanation for this
i mean are they just gonna say
it is so well more or less that
is what they say okay they say that the
ball rolls
turns as soon as it hits against the
wall you have this
interaction right uh kind of like the
decoherence stuff that
it interacts out with its environment
because it hits something
and now it's uh gonna act a little
differently
okay and so you say well what is the
explanation how
for this and here's a nice fine young
lady who
explains it for us i assume she has a
degree i haven't
really looked into her past but she has
a
youtube channel she tries to explain it
and this is what she explains okay and
she explains that
she knows nothing that she has no clue
okay here it is her name is uh jade tan
holmes
and she's a cute little girl that's
great but uh
here we do science we don't do beauty
you want to do beauty patient
passion pages
uh well you gotta go uh somewhere else
so she says it may seem stalling that
we're treating the wave function exactly
like an electromagnetic wave whatever
that is because you treat a wave
function
as a wave you haven't made much progress
they're both concepts they're both verbs
a function is an equation and a wave is
an equation also there is no such thing
as a wave
wave is a bunch of vectors that are
moving somehow because they make a move
in
mathematical physics she says it's hard
to imagine
something so abstract like the
probabilities of electron locations
as a real physical thing that travels
and reflects
and tunnels yeah it is it doesn't strike
her
i mean uh it doesn't snap her out of it
that hypnotism that something is wrong
are we just going to accept this and bow
down and say yes
to the professor because he's gonna be
the
supervisor of my thesis
the truth is scientists still don't know
exactly what a wave function is
they don't know what a wave function is
well i'll tell you what it is lady
a function is an equation that's how it
is it's a bunch of numbers
or a bunch of letters that represent
numbers etcetera
so yeah we do want to know what a wave
function is it's got nothing to do with
physics
physics deals with objects and this is
math that's what it is
they don't know whether it's purely a
mathematical tool
we're created we've created to help us
predict things about quantum
objects or whether it's a real physical
wave
my god poor girl i mean
it is a mathematical tool hopefully a
wave function
only has to do with math but it turns
out the wave also
has only to do with math there is no
such thing as a physical wave
because you have to identify what it is
that's waving
you know when you do the simulation in
front of the class
uh in college well you take a string you
move it up and down you know uh
got one here yeah maybe here something
like this okay
i hope you can see that's a very thin
black wire okay
and when they do that okay why can you
see
the wave well because they put a
physical object in this case
some kind of thread some some entity
elongated entity
then you can wave it up and down and you
can talk about wave because what's
waving
is the string the thread the rope
whatever you're using
but there is no such thing as a wave
without a
physical mediator and she's talking
about a real physical wave
oh what's the wave made of what is this
wave
you know are we talking about a string a
robe
what is this wave and she thinks it's a
real physical thing
that's what she was learned by wrote in
college
uh in order to get her degree and now
she goes on youtube and uh just peddles
the same thing she memorized by heart
for the test is this science
or is it poetry where you just recite
what you learned by wrote but what are
they what they do
know this is what they know we know
i don't think i know i don't think you
know either
what they do know is that it can be
modeled pretty much
perfectly by wave mechanics
i don't care if they can be modeled by
wave mechanics if that's an equation
that's what she's talking about again
we're missing the object we don't know
what
what uh what's waving what physical
object is doing the waving
and so this is so she hasn't explained
anything
and you wonder you know why she on
youtube
and she does a lot of videos just like
so many others out there
uh where they supposedly go in there say
oh i can explain how quantum
works or let me tell you a little bit
about relativity or strength theory
and what they do is they repeat over and
over again for the last 50 years the
same old same old stuff
she hasn't uh contributed anything new
and you say bill aren't you being a
little harsh on this girl i mean she's
just trying to make a living uh
going on youtube etc no no we have to
embarrass these people
there's so many of them they're crowding
out the inner they're crowding out
youtube they're crowding out so many
other
platforms out there and all they do is
repeat the same thing that the other guy
next
door said you know it used to be that
we needed a teacher in every class if
these people are going to be doing
teaching you know on youtube
all we need is one teacher for the
entire world everybody can tune in to
that teacher
from any part of the world and learn the
same thing we don't need the same
material being given by you know
thousands of different people
now you might say well maybe i like the
way this person says it instead of that
one yeah fine
how many versions do we have for quantum
how many versions do we have for general
relativity how many questions
uh versions do we have for string theory
do we need i mean let's assume we have
10 versions of quantum mechanics
different ways of explaining something
do we need any more
we have thousands of these people on the
internet what are what are they there
for
to say the same thing as the guy next
door said to say the same thing they all
learned by wrote in college without
providing anything new without giving
you an explanation instead of just
giving
instead of all they give you is a
description
mathematical description uh said in
uh english you know in regular language
in vernacular so they they give you this
presentation they say look this is this
is what the mathematicians mean
and this is how i translate it for you
you
uh people who are lay laymen okay
or lazy men and so they
they give you this version and they're
all giving you the same version
maybe the guy focus is a little
different than the other guy again
with 10 people we should cover the whole
planet we don't need more than 10 people
on
on youtube explaining the same thing
over and over and over again
what we have is thousands of people
because they're out of work and they say
look i got my degree should i go and
look for a job at a company no this girl
said well i'm
kind of cute i think i can go on the uh
youtube and make
some money just spreading the same thing
that all the other guys do
you know and she's cuter than the gal
next door well maybe they'll watch her
instead of watch the other
lady is that what science is about and
this is all we have today
all we have is these people just
crowding out the internet
getting thousands of vote lots of ups
everybody likes them you know say oh i
like i like i like to
what do they learn they learn the same
nonsense that they're gonna learn from
anybody else and they all
say the same exact thing and we haven't
made any
inroads in a hundred years not one of
these people can explain to you like she
says right there
they don't know they don't know they
don't know they don't know
all they know is that it works that they
saw an effect
and they can use that effect because it
works they can use it in some kind of
technology and and they say that's as
far as we can
go and they call that science
okay so yeah we don't we don't have an
explanation today
for any of the things these people do
okay so uh here's uh
the moving vectors that i was talking
about
okay this is let me get this one out of
the way here
uh what you're seeing there is a moving
vectors
okay this is what they're saying uh
that you're that they're looking you're
seeing or that's what they're imagining
because they don't see this they're
imagining that this is what's
in that invisible world but what are you
staring at you're staring at a bunch of
vectors what are those arrows
they're just vectors mathematical
vectors
what is that magnitude and direction and
you have magnitude and direction which
is moving
that's what you're staring at so yeah
these people have no explanations for
that invisible world of quantum
mechanics and the main reason for that
is you cannot see or touch
the mediators of gravity of light of
magnetism you can't see or touch them
you can only visualize them you know
close your eyes and try to imagine how
mother nature could be doing this
process
what the mechanism that she's using in
that world
and hopefully you do it with objects
because otherwise you're introducing
black magic
so you have to have an object what is an
object is that which you can see and
touch
no it's that which has form which has
shape
okay so what are my conclusions uh for
all these
effects these quantum effects well here
it is
conclusions quantum fails to explain the
key mechanism what are they decoherence
is irrational
entanglement they cannot explain it's
irrational superposition also irrational
shortening your cat being dead and alive
at the same time
irrational until you observe until you
peek inside the box
complementarity duality that light is
both
a particle and a wave irrational
uncertainty uh that the
ball stands still at the same time it
moves and when it moves it doesn't stand
still when it stands still it doesn't
lose
well that's quite rational it's just
incredible that they needed an equation
to explain that
which you know any kindergartner could
have told you
okay spin irrational why because it's
not spin and even if it were spin you
cannot explain
attraction uh action at a distance
attraction
with two tops that are spinning how does
one top affect another top
i don't care how they're spinning so
it's irrational because the mechanism
the fact that it spins even if it did
spin which it doesn't but even if it did
spin
you cannot produce pull which is the
only force missing in quantum mechanics
tunneling tunneling is irrational why
because
they convert the ball into a wave they
convert the photon
or the electron into a wave they say
it's got both features it's both a
particle and a wave and they
go back and forth because that's the
only way they can uh get it through the
mountain the ball
through the mountain and no problem
we'll even concede all that
i just need the process i need to know
the mechanism
by which a particle converts into a wave
and a wave back to a particle when it's
on the other side of the mountain
now how's that for an explanation that's
what we need we need an explanation
if you don't have an explanation whether
then all you're doing is black magic all
you're saying
is it is so it is so
i haven't learned anything because
you're telling me that you know one
thing converts my magic
into the other what's different than
that than saying that jesus christ went
to heaven
came back and then went back again i
guess right back and forth
and you say well that's superstition
what is this what is this nonsense is it
i mean what do you want to call this
superstition you call it uh
instead of superposition superstitious
probably a better word
it's nonsense this is poppycock this is
idiocy
and we've been living with this now for
almost 100 years
not all of them at the same time they
they
invented they discovered these phenomena
as time went by but this is what we have
today
this is the summary okay corollary no
wonder bore heisenberg feynman
among others you know everybody else in
quantum
candidly state that no one understands
quantum
mechanics no kidding
okay folks let's get to the questions
and comments that people made
we have a few of those let's go with the
first one here
one fellow says squares have shapes so
then where are they
where are they they're here they're in
your mind they're
they're in their brain okay that's where
they are
if they don't have location they are not
objects
well for that you have to define the
word object in such a way that you can
use it consistently
okay and objects are that which have
location and shape light doesn't have
shape
light doesn't have shape prove that
light is a torque
[Laughter]
poor fellow okay uh
let's show first we must define the word
object before we define the word
location in physics see you can't define
location before object because uh what's
at the location
okay you need an object at a location
otherwise there is
no such thing as location okay and so
first you gotta define location before
you find object therefore
no the word object is not uh shape
and location and it can't be can't be
both because location has to be defined
afterwards
uh nevertheless once you define location
object plus location that's what the
definition of exist
is and object and exists are not
synonyms which is what this fellow
believes which is what again
david hume and emmanuel kant essentially
believed
that there was no difference between the
word object and the word exist
and yes there is there's a difference
and that is the word location
an object with location exists one an
object that does not have location
does not exist what are those objects
that don't have locations
well they're imaginary objects the ones
that you
think about that you can imagine that
you can visualize it's also
2d objects they have no location what
has location is the ink
the paper the screen the pixel maybe you
know those
those uh have location but the
superman on that screen or on that piece
of paper
superman is an object it has shape but
superman does not exist
okay so it has no location the word rock
is
always an object okay no matter where
so are you going to say that rock is not
an object because
you have a rock that does not have
location you have a rock that you're
imagining
you have a two-dimensional rock
scribbled or drawn on a piece of paper
so that you call it rock and you're
saying that's not an object even though
it has
shape okay just because it doesn't have
a location
so no the word rock the word table the
word chair all these three
all these are objects anywhere in the
universe the word rock
is uh belongs to the set of
objects always whether it's imaginary 2d
or 3d or existing or whatever doesn't
matter
light is mediated by an object and there
you see it right at the bottom okay in
the classical mechanics you have one-way
mechanisms only one way
uh it could be
you know particles corpuscles or it
could be waves which
is not a physical object but even
assuming it's a physical object
it's one way and then quantum mechanics
has uh
those same two uh but again
they turn the particles into not core
puzzles
but essentially they're nothing they're
equations they're
they're uh formulas that's all they are
and what they've done is they've blended
the two in what is known as the
wave packet that's uh what's his name
um roger penrose's uh
squirrely wave packet there a little
kernikew with an arrow through it but is
also one way
okay rope hypothesis is the only one
that is a two-way
first it's a physical object because it
has shape
we're talking about a rope-like
mechanism looks like dna
if that helps you visualize it and it's
a
two-way mechanism because it it torques
and torsion goes both ways
and torsion is also the fastest thing
known to man
okay there's nothing faster than a
torsion wave if that's what you want to
call it a three-dimensional torsion
wave okay next issue
fella says or ass says ropes of what
dreads of what there is no such thing as
an electron
it is a mathematical concept aha
okay let's look at the threads of what
uh question there okay let's find out
okay uh what he's doing is meteorology
uh asking uh what is an elephant
well an elephant is what it's made of
an elephant is gazillions of atoms well
for that matter
so is a bear so is a table so is a tree
they're all gazillions of atoms so is
that how you're going to define it by
how many atoms it's got what it's made
of
it's known as meriology and we don't
deal with emeriology in science
it belongs strictly to religion what uh
the standard that what is the stanford
um
dictionary of philosophy does you know
these philosophers they do this kind of
stuff meteorology it's religion it's got
nothing to do with science at all
it's just nonsense it's what an object
is made of
we don't deal with that elementary
fundamental
uh entity that's what we're talking
about here and
so you can't say what is a rope made of
rope is made of
two threads very easy i mean here
it is okay here's here's my rope my
favorite rope okay
two threads two strings uh two whatever
you want to call you it's even two ropes
uh tight around okay so what is a rope
made of two
two whatever threads whatever you want
to put in there two cords
two uh cables two wires
now you say what is the thread made of
ah
the thread is not made of anything it's
a fundamental entity
and only irrational people continue
asking well what is it made of
well if you ask that question it means
you didn't understand what an elementary
entity what a fundamental entity is
a fundamental elementary entity get this
right okay in your
tiny brain okay a fundamental entity is
one that is not made
of anything the buck stops there
you can't continue saying like the
quantum mechanics do to create job
security
they say uh well we found this particle
okay we'll call it the alpha particle
okay
what is the alpha particle made of and
they say we'll give us some money and
we'll break it up into pieces with these
super colliders
okay they go in the lab they break it up
they say oh we found these traces there
and we found that the alpha particle was
made of gazillions of beta particles
we could peer deeper we broke that
particle up now it's made of
all these little chunks and we'll call
them beta particles
okay great so now the reporter at the
end of the room said what is the beta
particle made out of
and the mechanic says well it's a
fundamental particle what does that mean
well so far
as of today we don't know what it's made
of so
uh you don't have an answer for us well
yeah i'll have an answer if you give me
more money
i'll build even a super collat one as
big as the moon or as big as
the orbit of jupiter i'll smash
the beta particle i'll tell you what
it's made of
and so they give money they build the
collider they smash the beta particle
and they say it's made out of gammas
and they just keep going on and on and
on and on
until you know finally the buck stops at
some point because they don't have
enough money
to build a collider as big as you know
the uh
milky way galaxy and they say well
unfortunately we don't have a
uh you know collider big enough
to smash them to tell you what it's made
of what is what gamma is made out of
so the way we do it in science is a
little differently we don't go to the
lab and smash particles and
and then try to figure out what that
particle is made out of that's
meteorology that's nonsense
what we do is define we say a an
elementary
or fundamental entity is one that is not
made of
anything any sub uh part
it's not made of anything itself it is
the thing that comprises everything else
seeing quantum doesn't want to do that
because it's the end of their reign if
they say well look
the all particles are made of i don't
know gammas
okay so uh all particles the gluons
the uh higgs
uh the quarks every the electrons
everything is made of gammas whatever
gammas is
and then the reporter asks what is a
gamma made of
and that's what this person's asking
well what is the fundamental entity
made of it's a fundamental ending you
got to start somewhere
you can't continue just going with a
question and over and over and over and
say what is this made on what is that
made of what is the other guy made up
that's mariology in science we say
there's a fundamental entity comprises
everything else that's where the buck
stops and that's known as the thread
single thread that makes up all matter
in the universe
now we have a starting point and you
can't say what is it made of it's made
out of thread that's what a thread is
made of thread that's what
uh but quantum loves that you know
because uh
see again they don't look at uh objects
they don't look at things they don't
have any idea what the thing the
invisible intangible things that mother
nature uses
so they just put particles there and
they leave it at that
and they just work with particles they
simulate everything with particles
whenever they can't they use the wave
but generally it's the particle they
explain almost everything with particles
y because they can put a value
which is what a particle really is a
value in an equation
but then they say well you know what is
the coherence oh we don't know well what
is entanglement oh we don't know how
does that work we don't have any idea
but they don't care about that because
what they say look we observed
the effect in the lab okay
they observed the effect in the lab they
don't know how it happened
they have no idea because they're going
to try to do with particles and there
ain't no particles out there but they're
going to explain it they're going to
simulate it with particles
now they're going to use the effect
where in technology
and they say oh look we have a quantum
computer or was it a quantum
computer i thought it was a classical
because you build it with atoms and
atoms
and above are classical and everything
that we can see and touch is classical
and you're saying this is a quantum
computer yeah because we're using the
effect
that we cannot explain but that we
observe we
we tested and saw that this effect
repeats itself every time we do this
this is what happens and we're going to
use that what happens
in the computer so they have no idea
it's like saying
here's a magnet and i can pick up uh
iron filings okay how did that happen
oh we have no idea but look how neat it
is every time we put a magnet it lifts
all these iron filings and so they say i
can use this
you know i can uh lift cars with this
at the uh record you know uh
the wreck yard there all these cars i
can get a magnet and pull them up
how does it do it oh we have no idea but
look how neat it is we can use the
technology because we've
observed the effect and this is
essentially what these people are doing
these people are saying we can use the
effect we'll call it a quantum effect
and then some people come to you and say
well you know you wouldn't have that
computer if it weren't for quantum
others and see people who don't
understand what the issues are
the issue is they saw an fa they saw an
effect
they observed the effect they observed
the classical part of the effect
something that happened the part they
can see measure etcetera
and they're going to use that effect in
a computer they call it a quantum
computer
why is it because they built it out of
parts that
small parts sub-atomic particles that
they understand and they know how they
work no
absolutely not they they only see
the visible part the tangible part
that's what they're going to put in the
computer
and they're going to say if we do this
this is what will happen we don't know
how or why but it does happen
and they call that proof evidence and
that's where they get the
title or the adjective or the qualifier
quantum computer quantum dot
or whatever they have all these things
why because
you know they they can get away with
that okay
so yeah
that's the context for quantum mechanics
okay
uh next question or comment person says
says your thoughts on the next step in
the rational method after you have two
or more rational explanations for a
single thing
okay is that where it stops or do we
do religion and pick one rational
explanation over another
yeah at that point you do religion you
can choose any
theory you like you know i like uh i was
talking about the neanderthal theory the
fact that they were born in europe
and they never went uh south that's the
one i like that's one i use as an
assumption for
my theories okay so what
became a theory now becomes a hypothesis
a
starting point for a new theory okay and
you might say well i think something
different i think the neanderthals came
from africa
or from asia or whatever from america
american indians were neanderthal after
all you know they have more neanderthal
blood than europeans remember american
indians have more neanderthal blood
so you know you can have any starting
point you want
you can believe in any theory you want
but the issue is that
belief has to do with religion
assumption is a little different
assumption you're just gonna assume
the theory that theory that someone got
out there is true
and you're gonna use it as a foundation
for another theory okay
and someone can challenge that and say
well i don't agree with your assumption
okay fine but uh because of this this
and this you can criticize it
but the issue here is that that's the
way science works
belief is something different belief is
religion
knowledge when you know something you've
got a religion
okay that's uh known as religion what is
uh knowledge
justified true belief so said mr um
plato
okay another fellow says brings up
girl kenny wielder okay he says by the
one and only ken wheeler
i guess he's a follower of mr wheeler
tank and what does wheeler say he says
counter space
also accurately called the ether realm
whoa
the ether realm zero point energy
whatever that is
or simply the ether whatever that is the
realm of pure potential
whatever that is okay or unmanifest
energy of which by which
and from which nothing is possible or
even theoretically potential
without saying i don't know what he said
okay counter space is the no point
opposite of cartesian forms masses
magnitudes and phenomena okay great so
far we have nothing
okay there are only two dimensions in
nature okay we have length width and
height no
maybe just length width maybe width and
height no he says there's only two
spatial and counter spatial
okay that's counter space okay counter
space for me is you know how much
space i have for my beer on the counter
and the bar but they have some other
idea for counter space okay
says counters there is the no point
opposite of cartesian okay there are
only two dimensions in nature
to more accurately dimensional and
non-dimensional
okay so it's a yin and yang either you
have dimensions or you don't and
dimension there's only one dimension
because the other one is non-dimensional
meaning so you have a zero dimension and
a one dimension
so there are not two dimensions there's
only one dimension
okay whatever anyways he wrote uh a
paper
i encourage you to look into it okay
definitions of nature
and phenomena with a primer on cosmology
and ontology
oh my god must be important he gets uh
this stuff from a book that mr wheeler
published which is this one uncovering
the missing
secrets of magnetism and
uh you can look this book up it's on the
internet mr wheeler has made it
downloadable free okay free of charge so
you can just go in there and look at it
and the only thing i'm going to say
about that book
is that i challenge anyone uh i'll buy
a beer to anyone who can understand it
and i'm not asking you to read the whole
book please you'll be tortured
[Laughter]
it's it's not that it's not well written
i've never seen a book that i
cannot read and that's mr wheeler's book
you cannot read it's unreadable
i'm not talking about poorly uh written
i i've seen a lot of stuff that's poorly
written his is not poorly written
you cannot possibly understand it
it's impossible to understand just like
his videos a lot of them you know
most of them really you cannot
understand what he's talking about why
because he throws a lot of words around
that he's just to show off that he knows
how to pronounce them that's about it
because he never defines him he doesn't
define him in any of these two books
and you know so again i encourage you to
look those
books up and again i'll buy you a beer
if you can understand it
i i promise i'll buy you a beer
okay okay uh
another fella here says uh
oh this comes also from wheeler's book
and listen to this this is
interesting and important because uh
wheeler
uh mentions uh newton he
mentions a second he should have
mentioned newton first but it doesn't
matter really because he's going to
mention newton and he's going to
invoke also james maxwell and this is
what he says for newton that newton said
this
and again he doesn't include the the uh
actual uh words that newton said
uh and again it shows that he doesn't do
any research he doesn't go in there and
look at the
original sources he wrote something
which is not what
newton said verbatim okay and there's a
difference
but let's just go with i pulled up the
actual one that
uh newton had in his letter to bentley
that's
the unconceivable listen to this okay
that inanimate brute matter
should without the mediation of
something else which is not material
operate upon an effect other matter
without mutual contact
that one body may act upon another at a
distance through a vacuum without the
mediation of
anything else by and through which
their action or force be conveyed from
one to another
is to me so great in absurdity and he
kept going
okay he's saying you need a mediator
a physical mediator he cannot figure out
what but he says you need a
mediator otherwise it doesn't make any
sense that's what newton's saying
he says gravity must be caused by an
agent
acting constantly newton said this okay
okay that's newton okay here we have uh
maxwell
he comes in a few centuries later but he
says
uh something along the same lines and
this again this quote comes from
um uh this fellow curly uh what's his
name
um ken wheeler he says
uh maxwell says there appears to be an
in the minds of these eminent men some
prejudice or apriori objection against
the hypothesis of a medium
in which the phenomena of radiation of
light and heat
and the electric action at a distance
take place
the existence of a medium in which light
is propagated
okay he's talking about a medium he's
talking about an entity something that's
got to be in there
whenever energy is transmitted from one
body to another
in time there must be a medium or
substance
in which the energy exists after it
leaves one body
before it reaches the other okay so here
we have two
researchers a little old now but uh they
both said exactly
it came to the same conclusions okay and
that's what uh wheeler is trying to say
here okay
and let me get these two fellows out of
here for a second
so what does wheeler say because he
brings these two
he he quotes these two gentlemen mr
uh newton mr maxwell he quotes him like
saying see
you gotta follow these guys okay okay
let's see if mr wheeler follows them
what does wheeler say
and he says this right immediately after
right he says the following
and this is uh mr wheeler there he's
always an angry buddhist
angry monk says the
single greatest fear you can instill in
any materialists
okay so he doesn't agree with
materialness
even though what did we just hear from
uh newton and
james mancho that you need material
something you need a substance you need
a thing
there but he's gonna criticize
materialist is to ask him to define
a field okay atomic operations are
mediated by and through a field
oh i thought a field was a bunch of
numbers
that's not a physical entity that's not
material that's not what newton
and maxwell were talking about they were
talking about in physical entity
a field is not a physical entity field
is defined as
a bunch of numbers so yes uh
materialists know what a field is it's a
bunch of numbers it's a bunch of
values around the center point and
declining
the further away you get from it it's
strength
so that's all it is the field is a bunch
of numbers that's
all the field is all fields are the
ether
okay so uh ether is a bunch of numbers
i guess that's what he's saying right
because that's the definition of field
until he defines it otherwise
okay so the definition of field that
everybody uses out there
bunch of numbers okay that's all it is
all fields are modalities of the ether
without exception
any conception of action at a distance
without an ether
field redundant he says all ethers are
fields okay but he says in ether field
as mediator is a logic illogical
senseless and impossible
well uh a field is a bunch of numbers
that's not a physical mediator so
it's not a mediator not for the purposes
of physics
and so if mr wheeler doesn't understand
that well he's got a long ways to go
he's got a
steep learning curve ahead of him okay
yeah field is not a physical object
sorry to inform you look up the word
field you'll find it's a definition and
the definition says
that it's a bunch of values that's all a
field
is in fact it's not a noun you shouldn't
say a field or
the field because that turns it into a
physical object in physics
in science we don't talk about fields
like that only mathematical physicist
physicists uh talk like that okay
anyways uh you look up he says all
fields are ether okay let's see what
says you know uh ether can with a or
with
a e either way so he's got ether okay
what is an ether ether is pure potential
potentially that's a physical object
potential
what the hell is a potential sounds like
math
not cartesian counter spatial inertia
whatever that nonsense that is inertia
means that you have resistance to push
that's what it so again we're not
talking about a physical object we're
talking about the effects here
the essence of all field modalities yeah
which means that
field inertia potential ether
all this all these words that he uses
none of them are physical objects
so he's trying to do he quotes newton he
quotes
maxwell who talk about entities and he's
treating these
as entities in his mind he thinks these
are entities
things objects bodies substances
absolutely not these are mathematical
concepts
abstractions you can't do pull with
field
you can't do pull with wave you can't do
pull with
what uh inertia
modalities or whatever
fields whatever thing that
he's just using words ether you know
he's just using words
uh and yeah so-called indefinite diet or
attribute of
the absolutely just telling nonsense
absolute nouns that poppy cup none of
this has any
uh value in physics whatsoever he's got
a lot of followers uh
obviously people who say oh i understood
yeah come and explain it with
objects okay don't use counter spatial
don't use
field don't use any of those words i
want to i want you to draw
the physical mechanism of attraction
that's what i want you to do
whether you do magnetism or gravity do
it do it with
physical object i want to see what you
draw i want to see what you
put your mechanism
in motion show me the movie don't talk
show me the movie if you can do that
then you understood
you understood attraction you understood
action at a distance
effects otherwise you don't what are you
going to do put a field what are you
going to draw for a field
a bunch of numbers
okay uh fellow ass
oh here it is are the threads of the
magnets also connected to the ropes
and now the answer is no threads are
twined
and are connected to atoms not the ropes
nothing is connected to the rope itself
if it were we could see the ropes
because imagine you know here you have a
rope
and imagine one perpendicular to that
attached to that then we would see the
vibration coming along that rope to your
eye and you would see
the rope the reason we can't see the
rope is
we're lifting looking along the rope
which is torquing the torsion
is the is the is light
but light is the sensing point
it's stimulating an atom and that's
sensing
that that stimulation of the atom the
fact that the atom is
quantum jumping then quantum jumps
faster or slower
that's what we detect it's the pumping
of the atom that
is light for our eyes the mediator is
the rope but
but we don't see the rope itself what
we're detecting is the pumping of the
atom
at a given frequency that's what we
detect
we we detect the atoms in that sense not
light itself
so no the threats you cannot you cannot
see them and again there you see
clockwise and counterclockwise how the
threads
attract and repel the one on the
left is attraction and what you have is
they're both going clockwise so one is
when one comes down the other one clips
into it
and pulls it and the other one is
they're hitting against each other
pushing each other away
okay so that's how the threads work now
uh the threads
uh come out of the electron shells they
slide out when atoms are spinning at
great speeds which is
what happens during electricity so it
spins
perpendicular to the spin of the
atoms of the electrons essentially that
form the atoms right
the electron shells and that's when the
threads come out and they swing
around okay they swing around the
row of atoms which are bound to each
other which are merged
with each other and uh
so so that's what's spinning that's what
the threads
that's what the threads are doing
they're spinning around and both threads
spin i think someone asked that question
let me see here
yeah here it is well it says i have a
question about the rope is there a
qualitative difference between the
electric thread and magnetic thread the
answer is no
magnetic thread swings around why could
the electric thread be
always straight originally that was my
idea
some years ago okay and we changed that
i'm saying we because my son suggested
maybe both of them
um come out okay
they could come out of the rope or they
could come out of the electron shells
okay either way but what you have is a
single thread
in the entire universe there i show two
threads because some people say well
then it doesn't exist because it doesn't
have locations an object that doesn't
have location with respect to another
thread
so to quiet those people down we put two
threads because there could be a
parallel universe out there in that case
the thread does exist and all threads
exist
okay so maybe maybe there's another
thread out there that forms another
universe and
none of the atoms from this universe are
attached to the atoms of that universe
uh that's just uh academic okay
just for food for thought but the real
issue here is what you see at the bottom
we either have
the electron shells they're spinning
around they swing the
threads that come out of the shells
themselves or we have
like you see there on the right bottom
right
the rope disentangles and
and the the threads come out they could
also come out
like i showed there also in a second
there you'll see it coming
out of the row of electron shells
so it could be either way okay
either way we can explain uh what
magnetism is what is magnetism
bunch of threads that are swinging
around the electro magnetic field that's
what i'm referring to
okay okay another question
fellow says
torsional waving is different because
the strength of direct and direction
counterclockwise and clockwise of a
twist is the constant for
the duration of the twist there is
constant amplitude along the rope it
goes around around instead of
up and down okay he's talking about the
row
whether it's going up and down or you
know it's going around
okay that's what he's referring to
overlaying two-twisting media of
constant amplitude just
results in double the amplitude no
matter the phase
shift okay because he's trying to figure
out uh
how the rope causes um
interference constructive and
destructive interference okay
in the case of the slit experiment you
know remember or the needle experiment
as i call it
that's a better experiment really uh we
have one rope
hitting an atom in the um on the screen
okay and you have another rope coming
from the other side of the needle or the
other side of
the slit going to the same atom so you
have two at
two ropes going to that same atom but
they're offset by
half a link and so if they're offset by
half a link you get a
destructive interference and when
they're both
uh in phase they you get constructive
interference
okay where you have constructive
interference there's
light where you have con destructive
interference
you have a dark band that's essentially
the theory
and it really uh i haven't invented that
uh
not not the part of thread the farther
wrote yes but
not the part of constructive and
destructive interference
caused by waves that's always that's
been around for quite a long time
and it's that if the two waves we're
talking about
again wet we're done transverse waves
okay meaning
you have the electric field and the
magnetic field okay
so if the fields are
in phase constructive interference if
they're out of phase
okay then destructive interference okay
uh so that's the notion that's where we
get this okay
just so you can follow along okay he
says the only way to get destructive
interference
is to twist in the opposite direction
with a rope
countertwine to the first absolutely not
and
we'll see this in a second oh as i meant
to understand that the structure of the
rope
wags count clockwise and
counterclockwise
while twisting in both directions one
after another
imitating a transverse wave no you got
it all wrong completely
didn't get anything right okay let's see
what's right okay
well from the rope model point of view
okay and the first thing we have to
do is analyze this okay so let's talk
about this for a second
we don't see light itself the
electromagnetic road
so it's not you're not going to be
looking at the rope what are you going
to be looking at the atoms
that's i hope that went through your
head okay
not the rope look at the atoms okay
first thing
we can't see one atom what we see is
bunches of atoms so when you look at the
screen like
in a slit experiment you're gonna look
at the fringes on the wall
well what are you staring at you're
whether you know it or not you're
staring at gazillions of atoms in each
one of those fringes
okay each one of those lines are looking
at gazillions of atoms it's not one atom
you're looking at
okay but we're going to analyze one atom
what's happening to one atom you're
supposed to multiply it mentally
in gazillions of atoms what are we
staring at we're going to look at the
rope no we're going to look at the atoms
okay you're focusing on the ropes it's
the atoms you got to focus on
okay let's get that straight
constructive both rows stimulate the
atom simultaneously
if they're in phase if uh
let's see if i can do it with this let
me move this aside for a second
get this out of here okay
uh let's see we got blue where's blue
here
and blue here see the blue is
ah blue is to the
to my left okay blue is to my left
so we're saying they're both in phase
but if one of these is turned around
and you got uh red on the outside blue
on the inside
they're out of phase okay but they both
converge upon a
single atom they come from
two different atoms on the needle or the
slit
so one comes from here the other one
comes from here okay so you got
one here and the other one here okay so
they're going like this
they're meeting at that atom if they're
in phase
they're both gonna stimulate that atom
two ropes one atom two ropes converging
upon one atom
they stimulate it in the same direction
because they're hitting it both with
blue okay
and so they're both giving it the same
um
impetus the same uh pulse and so the
atom what does the atom do
the atom was normal it was uh you know
before you turn down the lights it was
just
pumping it's at the regular speed now
you turn on the light
you turn on the laser right that's going
to hit him now it's going to stimulate
that i'm going to pump a lot faster
so it comes with invisible range
blue with blue they're in phase they're
going to give the same
uh signal to that atom the same thump
okay if they're offset
and one tries
in other words you get again red versus
blue
right one tries to give it
a a stimulus the atom is trying to
expand and contract
because of that stimulus but as soon as
it tries to expand the other one gives
it a counter stimulus
because it's it's coming half a
link behind so the atom's trying to
expand
when that second link comes in and gives
it a second
impulse so it's it's uh staggered
the pulses are staggered and the atom
does not manage to expand and contract
at this
same speed as the one that's in
constructive interference
okay now that's the explanation i hope
you got some of that you can always
revise it later on but here
is the visual visualization of that okay
i've shown this in the past but
obviously this fall did not see this
okay
the one on the top okay you don't have
the the light turned on
okay so that's why uh put the atoms
in black okay showing that they're
pumping at a regular
rate which is below the visible range
okay
all you're seeing essentially is the
screen now what happens
as soon as you turn the light on you get
the two
uh beams or the two ropes right
are in phase because they are in phase
they stimulate that atom to go to a
wider range
okay so it's pumping faster and it's
pumping in
it's synchronized where the the two
ropes are synchronized
the one on the bottom they're not
synchronized you can see that when one
comes in and the atom tries to expand
the other one hits it again and doesn't
allow it to expand so it's the atom
that's
got the problem the atom because of the
ropes right because of the signal that
receives or the stimulus it receives
from the ropes
they're they're staggered and so the
second one is counterproductive to the
first one
that's why you have a dark band okay
so um i hope you uh
look at that and if you have questions
well uh
raise it again but that's essentially it
you have staggered signals coming to a
given atom and again we're looking at
gazillions of atoms so you've
got gazillions of gazillions of atoms
and they're all doing the same thing why
because
when you have the needle or the slit it
really doesn't matter i like it with a
needle
because you can get an atom on one side
an atom on the other side they receive
the same signal from
the laser but that same signal from
those two atoms does not arrive
at that single atom on the screen at the
same time
if they're offset by half
link half link okay and
because the robe has all these different
nuances of torsion right different
uh degrees of twist
uh that's why you get a ray see when you
look at the fringes
it doesn't go uh light and dark
sharply there's a gradient there that
goes into dark and then a gradient where
it goes back to light
and that gradient is because you have
all these different turns
of the rope you know you have different
angles for each one of those
ropes the gazillions of ropes that are
coming from the needle
to the screen so you got to try to
visualize all that uh
mechanic mechanism okay uh final
question here
someone uh phil says
ropes a description of a belief
there's nothing of scientific method to
back it
okay does it even come close to being a
hypothesis
at least something in scientific method
to back it
up i guess definitely not a theory level
not at theory level meeting all of
scientific method and constantly
repeatable okay in other words i think
he
talked about repeating experiments that
you got to do some kind of experiment
okay what's the answer to all these uh
issues that this gentleman raises well
science is
not about descriptions or beliefs so he
got that first one
wrong science does not do description
science does not do belief that's
religion
math does descriptions religion does
believe science does
explanations no evidence to back it up
well we don't use evidence in science
evidence has to do with belief
uh which is religion okay so
look look up where you see belief and
you'll see that it's equal to religion
so evidence has to do with proving to
someone to convincing someone persuading
that person
and converting him to your religion
you're recruiting him
okay so no we don't use evidence in
science at all
yeah evidence is only used to persuade
the jurors
uh hypothesis that's equal to an
assumption
okay so it doesn't come close to being a
hypothesis yeah it's an assumption
rope is an assumption we're saying let
us assume that light is mediated by
a rope-like entity so it's an assumption
it's a valid assumption
a theory what is a theory says
definitely not a theory level yeah a
theory is an explanation
so we're explaining we're explaining how
light works we're explaining torsion
we're saying that
um light consists of
frequency and wavelength what are we
talking about we're talking about link
lengths links of links and frequency is
the number of links
so we can explain many things with the
rope model
and yeah physics explains mechanisms so
that's what
physics is about so we're within the
laws of physics or the rules of physics
or the foundations of physics
because what we do in physics is explain
mechanisms causes that's what people
want to
know people want to know how gravity
works people want to know what magnetism
is how many nature does that magic trick
of picking up
iron filings with a piece of metal from
far away
how does a mother nature do that that's
what people want to
know and for that you need physical
objects if you're going to explain
a mechanism okay
a cause you can't do it with concepts
you can't do a field you can't do it
with a wave you can't do it with mass
or any of those concept time and energy
and whatever nonsense they've invented
out there in mathematics
no you gotta you gotta use objects we
wanna see the mecha you we wanna see you
make the film the movie of how you
produce attraction
and if you're going to do attraction
action at a distance attraction
hopefully you're going to do with some
mediator physical mediator
if not you're doing black
magic okay with that i'll see you next
time we'll see you on wednesday and we
haven't finished
with uh quantum mechanics uh we have
some more properties a couple of them
left over still so we'll see that
bye-bye